if the mob didn't know before they'd
know by now never ever get on the bad
side of someone who was a goonie cuz
Goonies never say die they know that now
Gangster Squad gangster squad is
supposedly based on a true story it's
the story of these few cops who are like
we're trying to go after Mickey Cohen
this big gangster played by Sean Penn
but politics keep getting in the way if
they play by the rules they're never
gonna get the guys with a life screw it
they put the badges aside to do some
Dirty Harry [ __ ] to take this guy out
now when the movies like oh based on a
true story
I usually go on the assumption that is
[ __ ] until proven otherwise and that
doesn't really matter because it's about
these cops who put the badges aside to
do what they need to do to stop a
gangster they form a mob to take down
organized crime and that sounds badass
sounds like alright mobster movie and
Josh Brolin in cops and okay I guess
just gonna be like the untouchable but
in terms of stylistic vision and
execution it's not really like The
Untouchables two scenes into the movie I
was like this looks like Zack Snyder
directed it it just looked like a Zack
Snyder movie not that that's bad
I like Zack Snyder movies as long as
there's Zack Snyder movies that don't
involve a few crazy chicks in the
nuthouse who become samurais but it
doesn't mean gangster squads not fun you
have Sean Penn as the bad guy Sean Penn
is just bad news in this movie he no
longer has gone full [ __ ] he's gone
full douchebag he doesn't obey the rules
he just wants to take it all he will
kill people and their families which
sounds pretty standard mob but it's all
about how we execute it man Spicoli
losing his mind for the Thompson not a
bad day in terms of the Gangster Squad
Josh Brolin Ryan Gosling Michael Pena
then he's not a big name right now but
he should because he's a good actor
Robert Patrick t1000 he's the best
character in this movie he has a
six-shooter anytime someone has a Colt
single-action army just like a Western
cowboy but that's always I'm on that
person's side and the stones in the
movie and she's all hot and sexy and has
her thing with Sean Penn and Ryan
Gosling which is funny because i running
Gosling and Emma Stone together in real
life I can think of like three movies or
at least two were they bang in which
case look these attractive people need
to stop that because they're gonna have
really perfect super angel babies and
I'm gonna hate them forever
gangster squad is not going for an Oscar
it's pure entertainment and fun which is
weird to say that about a movie that's
supposedly based on a true story about
the mob
visually you're like all rise like
Boardwalk Empire but movie not like that
at all men I swear to god you would
think yourselves Zack Snyder
directed his movie that's not a bad
thing you know the shootouts are
happening you just got a bunch of tommy
guns just but it's all I'm slow-motion
the shells are flying out of the guns
you like alright this is completely
stylistic yeah you want a little more
substance out of a mob movie but it's
pretty straight forward I mean you can
watch the trailer and you have in your
mind you're like I think I know how the
movies gonna play out but the movies
gonna throw me some curveballs right no
no curveballs it's pretty
straightforward beginning to end it's
exactly how you think it's gonna be
everyone does a good job in Gangster
Squad they're all good actors there's
like one part where one guys like I'm
really having a moral dilemma with what
we're doing you know it's not right it's
not within the law it's one of those
things where if they didn't address it I
wouldn't even be thinking about it
because that door wouldn't be opened in
the movie but now they opened the door
to a moral dilemma which is fine if
you're gonna have a deeper movie but
this movie is not it's made purely for
entertainment so now I have to assess
how do they do in addressing the moral
dilemma now that they open that door I
was just one sentence it's no big deal
which means they didn't deal with it
very well so now I have to address that
in my video I mean if they really wanted
the movie to flow stick with the tommy
guns in popcorn you do that just fine
gangster squads like peanut butter and
jelly you open your lunchbox you pull
out a salmon yeah I have a lunchbox I
still use apparently I do with some
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers Green
Ranger lunchbox complete with thermos
not really I don't really have that but
if I did I would use it but now you pull
out the sandwich you're like peanut
butter and jelly I like me to butter and
jelly it's good you could have gone for
a more involved sandwich but peanut
butter and jelly it's simple it's good
it works fine I will say gangster squad
is a good time no alcohol required right
so what is your favorite mob movie
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you